What's the best way to learn programming? What
programming language should you learn? First?
Is AI going to replace developers? In this
video, you will hear answers to 10 of the most
common questions that people new to software
development tab. This collaboration video
features answers from a bunch of experienced
software developers and tutorial creators.
Will AI ever replace developers? Wow. Oh,
really? I was question. I answered this question
a lot. I don't think so. No, I don't think so.
No, I don't think so. Well, I don't think so.
Hard. No, the answer is no, I'm not seeing this
like our problem? Not really. And the short
answer is no, I do not think that AI will replace
developers anytime soon. I do however, think that
it will get rid of all the boring repetitive
tasks that we don't want to do and allow us to
focus on the problem solving and creating aspects
that software development count brain. Actually,
AI is our friend as developers, because it's
creating lots of helpful tools that reduce
the amount of work we have to do and
the amount of typing we have to do
to create new things and write code as developers,
I think it will enhance us as developers,
it will save us from doing this repetitive tasks,
something like an engine on the boat that helps it
to go faster. In my opinion, I think AI is a great
addition of the set of tools that we already have.
And it will allow us to be more efficient, faster,
and really speed up the development lifecycle.
With Auto completions that we've seen with some of
the tools that already are out there. AI is only
as good as the data that we put into it. If you
dig a little bit deeper into what AI exactly is,
it's just a dataset that is used for predictions.
Now, in the case of GitHub co pilot, for example,
the predictions are really, really good. It seems
to know what I want to type. So that is perfect,
but I don't think it will ever actually replace
developers because you know, we can still have
a lot of creativity that systems don't have and
consider this, there are still developers needed
to create the AI. What I think or what I see
happening is AI coming into the tech things help
eight developers productivity, or help automate
some of the tasks that developers have to do for
your day to day, I believe that AI will not be an
independent power tool that will just magically do
everything that developers do now. But rather,
it will be just one of the tools for developers
themselves to actually make their own work more
efficient and delegate some of their tasks AI will
help optimize developers work, but certainly not
replace them. I use Google copilot all the time,
and I'm not really worried about it. But if I were
the kind of person that would occasionally get
things very spookily, right, and then sometimes
crazy stuff that says wildly out of nowhere,
I might be replaced by co pilot. All the
traditional jobs we know and love today
will eventually be replaced by AI. I'm a big
believer in the singularity, and that eventually
artificial intelligence where it will surpass
human intelligence, that's always going to need
us to develop simple applications, complex
applications, hell even develop the AI that helps
developers, such as co pilot work the way it does,
AI will not replace developers because there will
always be jobs for programmers to work on small
scale, medium or large projects, AI will not be
able to do that all on its own, he can certainly
be useful and can assist in development processes,
but it will not do the whole thing on its own.
Unless, of course AI becomes self aware at which
point we'll have bigger things to worry about than
our job. I think that someone will always need to
maintain something, right? There's infrastructure
to be maintained. There's always going to be some
code to write someone needs to write code to
make the AI work. In general, I think that AI
even if we were to replace the typical jobs
that we do today, it just means that engineers
will have to adapt to something different, but I
don't think it's going to replace them completely.
What is the best way to learn programming, through
courses or by yourself? When you're just beginning
you need some kind of a guideline or roadmap
because you don't know what you need to learn in
which order you need to learn or generally you
have no idea where to start. So on a beginner
level, I recommend starting with courses and
then go ahead and practice with actual real life
projects. I think you will spend as the developer
most time of your life learning programming,
so the learning does not really stop. So if you
find courses beneficial than going for courses But
I'll tell you now, the ability to study on your
own is the one of the most valued abilities of the
developer. Honestly, I'm a big fan of courses
because they provide structure. And I think
having structure is very important when you're
learning something and you don't know where to go.
If you're simply learning a new language, you're
already proficient in several languages, that I
think the best way is to go by yourself, and just
read the docs and build projects. But if you're
starting from scratch, I think coding courses
and then also simultaneously working on projects
is the best way to go. In my opinion courses
will allow you to at least get the foundational
understanding, then you need to go by yourself and
start creating products, applications, websites,
etc. Using the skills that you've just learned.
I think taking a course is still technically
by yourself, but more structured. When you go
through a course you're going to learn new things.
But then it's up to you to take that knowledge
and apply it to your needs. Go build something on
your own after the course. Well, I would say is a
mixture of things, I would advise all my students
always watch the tutorial first. However, not just
rely on the tutorial too much, I would recommend
completely getting rid of what you've just built
the tutorial and just starting from scratch,
really seeing if you can do it all by yourself,
and really seeing if you can make the project
your own. Your best way to learn programming
is really what works for you. Do you learn best
by digging in a book going through a course or
even a combination of the two. But ultimately,
one thing that will help everyone is to practice
by creating projects, I had a math professor that
wants math is not a spectator sport. And the
same goes with programming you need to get
to practice and to get better. In my opinion,
I think through courses because you can find
someone that you fully understand and you feel
comfortable, like listening through the examples,
because some concepts can be really, really
difficult to grasp. If you just for example,
reading books or through blogs, whereas if someone
is teaching you and an explaining along the way
through, for example, videos, which I think is
one of the best ways of learning programming,
I think that will take you a long way as you start
off, then once you are comfortable and understand,
for example, the programming language or
the framework, this is when I feel like
by yourself is better, because you can challenge
yourself through wherever project that you think
will basically allow you to learn all the
skills that you've learned from someone else,
it's more like you if you're just getting started,
you need to go ahead and take some fundamental
courses about programming, maybe you learn web
development, JavaScript, you get the first steps,
you learn the basics, then afterwards, you can
jump on your own project and you start learning
by yourself. And this way, you will be able
to like explore and read more documentation
like how to solve problems by yourself, like
explore more libraries by your own portfolio.
And much, much more personally, I would say both
because being a self taught developer myself,
I relied a lot on online resources, like courses,
to help me learn some of the technologies that
I was learning. So you can do it yourself.
But to be honest, you still need to rely or
look out for resources online to help. The
answer to this really varies by two factors,
by your individual preference, and also by
the situation that you're in. For some people,
it's better to go the self learning route than
some people need the motivation, and the personal
involvement and structure that something
like a coding school or a boot camp brings.
There's no one path to get into coding.
What if everyone became a programmer? Well,
realistically, I don't think that will happen.
But I definitely do think that it will help if
everyone has some basic understanding
of how code works, how computer works,
because that will help for security, we will get
a more diverse set of people in programming. So
that will definitely help as well to break
some paradigms and get some creative new
things out there, which will be really great.
So I do definitely think that everyone should
have some basic knowledge of programming. But
Will everyone become a programmer? I hope not.
First off, not everyone is going to want to be
a programmer. People have different interests,
and there's room for everybody's interests and
passions in the world. That being said, I do think
that at least in school, everyone should learn
the basics of programming. I agree with Steve Jobs
here when he says everyone should learn how to
code because it teaches you how to think I think
that logic, like stepping through problems. And
all those related skills that kind of fit under
the umbrella of learning to code are really
valuable, regardless of what career you go into.
Also, coding skills can be very
helpful even in non coding jobs.
I've heard a lot of people who have used
a little bit of Python or a little bit of
Visual Basic to automate some of their tasks at
work and really help them out with other things.
Or maybe someone will learn to code and then just
use it for side projects, or building things that
they really want to exist for themselves
or for the rest of the world. And coding
creates an opportunity for people to be able to
do that. That's the beauty of learning to code.
You can take it anywhere and do so many things
with it outside of just working as a developer.
I don't think that is possible, mainly because
coding and programming is not for everybody,
some may like it, some may not like it. That
being said, though, if for whatever reason,
everybody decided to become a programmer, that
simply means that the demand on the job market
is very high for programmers, which is good for
everybody. This is really not worth worrying
about. I think if the concern is, what if there's
too many people in the job pool, and everyone's
trying to get into the same jobs? I think that's
already happening today. But if you take a look at
the software engineer salaries, they're still very
high. And that's because even with all the supply,
it's still very hard to find talent. So as long
as I think if you strive to be a good engineer,
it really is not a problem for you to think
about. Well, I think it's more of a self feeding
cycle. The more programmers we have, the more
awesome technologies and generally technological
progress we have. Which means we again, need
more developers for those new technologies.
However, I do think that the simple
coding and programming skills
will not be enough for a professional software
developer. So while some years ago, just average
JavaScript knowledge was a superpower. Now,
as a developer, you actually need to bring
much more skills to compete with other
developers, because again, the programming
field is rapidly growing and becoming more and
more competitive. Man, that's never gonna happen.
I'm not really worried about it, though. But it
would mean a worldwide shortage on Hot Pockets.
That would be cool. But it's not going to
happen. Don't worry about there being too many
programmers, the demand for talented programmers
goes up every year, as technologies advance. There
are tons of open roles everywhere. I'm 3040,
or 50. Is it too old to learn how to program?
No, no, definitely not. It's never too late to
start. It doesn't matter the age? Absolutely
not. I don't think it is ever too late to learn
anything. Absolutely, yes. Turns out that a switch
flips in your brain when you're 30 years old, and
you're unable to process new information, which is
why I don't know how Game of Thrones ended. But
I'm sure it ended well, well, I don't think so.
I think programming can be learned at any stage
in your life. Programming is a skill, it doesn't
really matter how old you are, like, literally,
you just have to be consistent. You can literally
learn to code at any point in your life. You can
learn programming at any age, I know people that,
you know, from the 30s 40s, they decided that
had enough from what they were doing. And they
just became a programmer. So it's completely
up to you whether you have the right mindset,
literally anyone, it doesn't matter
the age, anyone can learn how to code,
age doesn't mean anything at all. I don't think
it is ever too late to learn anything, basically,
as long as you kind of enjoy it, you know, maybe
a job can be harder at a certain age because of
all kinds of prejudice that is out there by
companies, which is, you know, not great. But
it's unfortunately the reality. But I feel if you
want to learn anything, the time is now, a lot of
things you need to get started with learning how
to code honestly is out there for free internet.
And there's a an abundance of information that
you can just grab whenever. So I truly believe
whatever limitation it is that you think you
have, it's probably not your age, it really is
just your own self belief of can you do it? Or can
you not do it? My recommendation would be to just
get started learn a little bit each day and just
see where that goes. I'm currently teaching my mum
to do some HTML, CSS and JavaScript. So I never
think Never Say Never always is a good time to
start learning anything really not just software
development. If it's either for a career switch
into a developer job, or just as a hobby
programming can be for anyone of any age.
Absolutely not. I think age, even though obviously
it is a real thing. It's also a social construct
all of these expectations around what time You
should be doing things at what age should you be
doing any particular tasks, those
are all just social constructs. So
I don't think you should believe anybody
that tells you you can't do something,
no matter what age you are, yes, it will be
harder to learn. Because when you're younger,
your brain is like a sponge, and it retains
information better. But regardless of your age,
you can 100% learn to code and you should,
if that's something you're passionate about,
I actually personally know a lot of people over 40
that started learning to code and now are getting
careers out of it, like complete career switches.
So now I don't think you can ever be too old.
These a diploma in computer science worth it
worth it, probably, but required, probably not.
But then again, this kind of depends on what
field of programming you're going after.
Some may require formal education, some may not.
It also depends on the location where you leave,
and so on. So I would say if you're able to
afford a formal education, go for it, then it
will be worth it. But if you can't, please don't
take out any loans, because it's not going to
be worth it in that case, that really depends on
your situation, if you have the money and time to
invest in a computer science degree, and it's also
the best option for you personally, and mentally,
then I would say yes, a computer science degree
would be great. It gives you lots of access
to professors who are knowledgeable about the
foundations of computer science, you're going
to get really great foundational knowledge of
software engineering, you'll also have access to
lots of resources, you'll be able to network with
people in the industry, maybe get internships,
that's a really good leg up into a career as
a software developer, many jobs will even say
they require a degree in computer science, or
that equivalent amount of experience on the job.
Web development in general can
definitely be done without a degree,
especially with all the free ways of learning
that are out there. Now, it's actually quite
easy to get started with programming without
going for a degree. Well, in my opinion,
the answer has been no, I have a diploma
that I got after I already learned to code,
and I've never used it. But if you can afford
to go to college, and have that experience,
I think it's good that people get that diploma,
so that they can have that experience of learning
how to learn in a real college scenario.
Do I think it makes you a better developer?
No. I have mixed feelings about this, because it
really depends on what career you want to pursue.
Personally, I don't think my computer science
degree was worth it. Because I could have learned,
actually, I did learn most of my knowledge from
YouTube, from online courses from free resources
from Google and Stack Overflow. That's where I
gained most of my knowledge. But what university
was very useful for is building a network
of people, providing you with opportunities,
and having a structured approach to learning.
So it's useful for those three things,
but it is definitely not necessary. So if
that's what's holding you back from entering
the tech world that don't get one, just learn by
yourself, maybe take a bootcamp but you can 100%
learn on your own and don't mind a computer
science degree or feeling like you need one
hold you back. I don't have one. But I think
it's fine. I think if you do get into this,
and you go through a boot camp, and they don't
teach you data structures and algorithms,
it is probably something that you want to follow
up on. And if you want to get into something like
machine learning, then some extra math would also
do well. But yeah, I don't think it's necessary
for a practical working job at this point. Well,
I personally don't have a computer science degree,
software development, or computer science wasn't
really something on my radar, I actually studied
architecture. So I did the math. I did the physics
and it just wasn't really a thing and wrong my
friendship group. So if I didn't do it, you
don't have to, of course it does help. But is
there a really hard prerequisite? Absolutely. If
you have time and money to go to the university,
go for it, because apart from the knowledge,
most importantly, you're going to meet the right
people. I don't think it's worth it at all. But if
you of course if you have a diploma, it's a great
add on you can add it to your CV and it's just
like a great add on for you. But for just been
getting a developer urine needed deployment you
can learn all by yourself. My short answer to that
is no. The longer answer is it filled specifically
has a big advantage that whatever there is to
learn, you can actually learn yourself from online
courses, YouTube videos, self practice, etc.
You can even create a portfolio of your projects,
host them into a git repository and show it to
your potential employers as an evidence of your
knowledge. Plus, I would argue that most of the
latest technologies or latest versions of the
established technologies aren't always taught at
universities, simply because they can update their
curriculum so fast to keep up with these changes.
I would say it is, I think that if you have one,
it might be a little bit easier to break into
the industry, although it does take a lot of time
and money. So those are your main considerations.
If you don't have a lot of either of those, then
perhaps a boot camp might also work for you. So
was it worth it? I think it was for me, is
it required though? Now, there's different
avenues nowadays to break into the industry, you
don't need a diploma to get started. I would say,
if you have the money, then absolutely yes, it is
worth it. Because computer science will teach you
things that will help you to become a better
programmer in the long run. However, if you
don't have the money, then I think that he should
maybe just try a bootcamp or for example, here in
the UK, the government is giving free 12 week
program for people to get into coding, which is
amazing programming influences your health, it's
a very sedentary job, you're sitting in front of a
computer for many hours every single day. And from
a physical perspective that can really take a toll
on you. I have implemented quite a few systems
to help keep me active throughout the day, I set
reminders on my watch. So my watch will vibrate
every hour, so and let me know that I need to
stand up and walk around for at least one
minute, it's very easy to get caught up in a
problem or writing code. And all of a sudden
eight hours goes by and you haven't eaten.
You haven't had any water or gotten up to do some
exercise. So be sure to take routine breaks. And
I really love my standing desk, it keeps me from
sitting all day. I do think that with any sort
of job, when you sit too long at computer,
it is important to get up stretch your legs,
get away from the computer every 20 minutes or so
even though that does seem quite hard. Now, when I
think about it, I definitely don't do that enough.
But I would say that taking short breaks, letting
your eyes rest is key when doing what we do. It's
very addictive. So I remember when I started,
as a junior developer, I just wanted
to you know, fix a bug from Friday,
I would spend Saturday and Sunday working on
it. And then Monday, and then carry on for,
you know, weeks and weeks just focusing on
programming without no break. And obviously,
that can have a big impact in your life. So
burnout is a common thing within programmers. Yes,
programming can have an effect in your health.
But I would say it's like everything, right? So
you know, just don't have too much of it. And it
won't be a problem. Well, it definitely makes your
brain more active and possibly saves you from
Alzheimer's. But because you sit down a lot,
you need to plan in a lot of physical activity
in order to stay slim, not great. It is a lot
of sitting down. And that's not particularly
awesome for your health. But I have noticed
that I do apply a kind of engineering rigor
to my workouts. And when I actually work out,
that actually helps a lot. So there is that? It's
kind of a funny question. But I think there's some
truth to it. Because if you really get caught up
in a problem with programming, then it's easy to
maybe drink too much coffee, do not get up enough
from your chair, maybe eat some unhealthy food,
because it's just easy, and you want to focus on
the problem. So make sure to get up exercise, eat
healthy, do all kinds of things, but also for your
mental state, right? It's very much a profession
where you have to think a lot. So make sure to
disconnect at times, do something completely
different to relax and not get too caught up
in complex problems that won't let you go.
Well, for me, it's quite an advantage because
I am remote and I get to work my own hours.
I get to go to the gym five times a week, if not
seven, and I get to Power Lift every single day.
So for me, I get to enjoy what I love at the gym,
and also get to program mentally. I use the gym to
give me clarity, as well as taking away any
stress I might have from the job that I do.
So a lot of times as developers we are literally
on our desk sitting for hours upon hours. And in
the long run this could cause back aches or
you can start having eye problems. So in this
scenario, what I would advise is, as well puzzle
should take care of yourself If you notice that
you're having back ache, you should definitely
get yourself an ergonomic chair that would help
you balance properly, or standing desks where you
can switch between sitting and standing. And also,
if you are having eye problems, because you're
always looking at the screen, definitely get
yourself a blue light blocking glass. This really
helps improve your eyesight as you work everyday.
Do you need to know math to become a developer?
Seriously? No, absolutely not. I don't know where
this comes from. I actually teach programming
in elementary schools to fourth graders, and
they have this idea that takes a lot of
math. So it's got to be like an episode of
Sesame Street or something, please don't watch
that episode. Now dubbing maths, well, it's
very helpful is not again, a hard prerequisite for
learning how to code. There are many avenues that
don't require any maths at all. For example,
when I was working as a software developer,
in my old company, the amount of maths I did
was very negligible. When creating games, for my
tutorials, it is a bit higher, but it just depends
what kind of area you go into. This depends again,
on what you want to do. As a programmer, for
instance, if you want to be a game developer,
you may need to know some math, especially if
you're working on game engine that will evolve
a lot of game physics. But in general, No, you
wouldn't really need any math to become developer.
know myself, I wasn't that good with Maths.
But still, I'm a software engineer, obviously,
depending whether you want to, you know, go into a
role where it's, you know, heavily maths focused,
such as a quant developer, then yes, you need to
know maps, but there are many areas in software
engineering that you don't need to know maths
at. All. Right. So also, it depends on on the
industry that you you're planning to go into.
But in general, you don't need maths? Well,
it depends on the type of developer. If
you're going to be doing machine learning,
or data analytics or quantum computing, then yeah,
but in general, you just need to know basic math.
Math is obviously a related field, right?
In programming, you're likely going to be
working with some form of numbers, you know,
you might be writing some algorithms. But does
that mean that you need to be a math expert?
Not necessarily. I think, you know, if you
do a typical CS degree, you'll have your learn
a little bit of math, but it doesn't necessarily
turn you into a mathematician or anything like
that. Right? So do you need to know some math?
Yeah, I think so. But do you need to be like
an expert mathematician? No, not really, huh?
Well, I don't think so. Like, literally, you can
be a developer without maths. Because at the end
of the day, depending on the kind of developer you
are, you don't have to deal with mathematics. So
for for example, if you're a front end developer,
you might need it at some point. For example, if
you're doing like CSS Calc, you need to know like
a bit of calculation table. To be honest, it's not
a deal breaker for you to become a developer. So
Max, is a good knowledge to have what not require?
Absolutely not. You don't need math skills to
become a developer, I would argue that if you know
fourth grade math, that will be more than enough
to start learning programming. What you need,
though, is a decent amount of logical thinking
skill, which you can easily develop with practice,
because programming is about being creative and
making logical connections and finding solutions.
So programming doesn't follow any
predefined mathematical formulas.
So if the fact that you're not good
at math is what's holding you back,
then you have nothing to fear about because
that's not going to be a roadblock for you.
How long does it take to become a junior Dev.
Now the natural progression of a developer is
very different depending on where you are mine
was to do a boot camp, then a graduate scheme,
and then become a junior developer. And all in
all, I think that process, including the boot camp
took a bout a year. So that is just something
that I went through, but again, is different for
everyone. Well, as computer science evolves, you
will probably need to know a lot more today than
you would have required to know in like, say
90, it's but think six months is a safe period,
considering that you will be say practicing at
least once a day, a guess for somebody who's
going to learn on a daily basis, it would be from
like four to six months to be a decent Junior Dev.
But for others who are just like learning from
time to time, I guess most of them is going to
be like 10 to 12 months to be a good Junior Dev.
There is no set amount of time that anyone can
promise you where you will be a junior developer
in so many months. Now I think it's really helpful
to get inspiration from people's stories where
they say, Oh, I became a developer in three months
or six months, and this is how I did it. But that
doesn't mean that it will be the same for you.
It could take you two years. And that's okay.
That's your own path. Also, everyone comes into
software development, with a different background.
I started coding HTML, probably when I was 11,
or 12 years old. Some people have almost
never used a computer or can barely use email.
And some people have already built lots of things
in programming languages. So you can never compare
yourself to other people. It depends on how
much effort you put into learning, depending on
your current circumstances, you may or may not be
able to invest the same amount of time as others.
In general, I'd say six to 12 months, but don't
compare yourself to others. Go at your own pace,
and don't rush, you're going to be a better
developer, if you take the time to really learn
the fundamentals, I could tell you that it would
take you three months to become a junior Dev,
but I might be wrong. Or I might be right.
It's really individual, because everybody
learns at a different pace. And everybody learns
different ways. So while it could take you three
months, it could take somebody else nine months
or even more. So don't be discouraged. If it
takes you a little bit longer to become a junior
dev than somebody else. Don't compare yourself
to somebody else. He took a and there is
nothing wrong with taking a little bit longer.
Take your time and just do what you're doing. It
will take you exactly as long as it's needed for
you personally to become a junior though. I think
it really depends. Online, you do you see a lot of
the best case scenarios. So you know, you see
people that learn to code. And in six months,
without a computer science degree or anything,
they get a job at Google, or you do see a lot
of people that learn to code and then get a six
figure salary three months later. I think those
are best case scenarios. And even though that
can happen, and absolutely yes, it does happen.
It's not the norm. And it's not what you should
expect. And I think it, it discourages a lot of
people because they have those high expectations.
But I think a realistic expectation for learning
to code. From day one to becoming a junior Dev
and landing your first job would be a year or
even more. I think building those foundational
skills would take at least six months,
I wouldn't trust anyone that tells you that it
can take less, I think we should set a little
bit more realistic timelines, which programming
language to choose first. Now this is of course,
a great question. And again, it depends on where
you are geographically or what you're interested
in. For me, I did HTML, CSS, JavaScript, and then
we've done to react and started looking at some
Python and some back end development as well.
But again, that is not a hard, you must do this,
it will be different for everyone up? Well, I
don't think there is one right answer to this,
I think that is the language that you enjoy
most the one that sticks with you. So try out a
couple of different languages and see whichever
one works for you. I also feel that if you've
mastered the wonderful art of programming, that
it doesn't really matter what language you use,
if you fully understand one language, you can
apply those concepts to any language out there,
I would go with JavaScript just because you know,
you can use it for front end, you can use it for
back end, you know, basically, you can do it for
full stack, you can use it for mobile development.
So you really, you can go all over the place with
JavaScript, and it's a multi paradigm language. So
there's a lot that you can learn about programming
with just that one language. So I think if you're
not sure, in my opinion, nowadays, JavaScript
is an absolutely great way to get started
100% What I would recommend is Python. Python was
my first programming language and what we learned
at university and that is because it reads like
English, it has a very simple syntax, it's easy to
learn, it's easy to understand, as a beginner, and
it can help teach you the foundations. If you do
want to do front end, then I recommend JavaScript
and obviously learning HTML CSS, in my opinion,
I think you should pick a language that will teach
you the fundamentals of programming well enough,
and as many concepts such as object oriented
programming, interfaces, types, for example,
right? Now, if you go into language that
doesn't teach you all of these concepts,
then you can find a little bit difficult to move
forward. So the benefit of learning for example,
language, such as C++, Java, C sharp, C, is that
whatever other language follows, you will see
so many similarities that you'll see that language
is just a tool for you to solve a problem.
Now, I'm a C sharp developer, I love the language
and I do think as a Great one to get started with.
But ultimately, I would probably choose Python,
mostly for there being so much learning material
for it. And it could be easy to get started
with C sharp is a very close second, then, if
I were starting out, I would go to the local job
market and see what's on demand and go from there.
Another way is to simply try out multiple
different languages and see which one you
would like, which is easier. Maybe you like the
syntax of one language better than the other,
and so on. People fall into a few different
categories when they're learning to program.
Some people already have a goal in mind of what
they want to do, for example, you want to become
a mobile app developer. While then you will learn
Java and or Swift to work in that ecosystem.
Now, if you don't know what you want to do,
there are two recommendations that I have
from working with students over the years. And the
first is that if you really have no background,
in programming, or much technology at all, or
if you are an artist, or very design oriented,
I recommend learning HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript first,
one great thing about that stack is it starts you
off with the most basic languages like HTML, CSS,
and gives you instant feedback in the browser, for
everything that you're building and the changes
you're making. The nice thing about that stack
is a browser is something almost everyone is
already used to using. So it gives you kind
of that comfortable place to start coding.
If you are a little bit more tech savvy,
and or you are not very good with design,
my recommendation is to learn Python first. It is
such a great general purpose programming language,
has a wonderful community, and is used in
pretty much every different type of programming,
from scripting to web development, Blockchain,
AI, all different sorts of things. This is kind
of a complex question. And I'm going to
preface it with it doesn't really matter.
But if you're a front end Dev, or you want to be
a front end, Dev, choose HTML, CSS and JavaScript,
get the basics down and move on. If you're a back
end Dev, choose a back end technology that excites
you, such as Java, Go Python, for example. Other
than that, it's just about picking something and
getting started. I mostly recommend to start with
JavaScript, because it's easy. It's flexible,
and is the most popular programming language for
developing web applications. Because programming
is generally pretty abstract. So starting with
web applications, where you can see the results
visually in the browser helps a lot to
understand what you're actually programming,
because you have some actual visual feedback.
Plus JavaScript can be used for both front end
and back end development. So with one language,
you actually learn the basis of the full stack web
development. For me, I started with C and C++. But
I guess for nowadays, it would be better to start
with something like JavaScript, or maybe Python,
but I see Java code is a better choice to go for,
since it runs literally everywhere. Give us some
tips on motivating yourself to study, I would say
start with a project, it will be something fun
to work on, instead of doing random exercises,
or going straight through a book or a course.
And with a project, you're more likely to go,
oh, I need to do this for to do what I wanted
to do. And you'll go and see how to do it. And
you'll learn how to do it at the same time. I
can share two themes here. The first step is
for you to create a study timetable. By having a
study timetable you've already set aside time for
when you would like to study this really helps you
because then there is no way you would say that,
for example, you don't have the time or
something else is blocking your time because
now you have a schedule. The other thing I'll
say is for you to find a study group, study group
really helps motivate you because do you have a
group of other people that you can look out to
that would help motivate you to go ahead and
study so having the study group is great.
And also setting a study thank you is also a great
way to be motivated. I guess the best way would be
to find what interests you the most and try to
learn it. Also I find a good way is actually
to follow video tutorials. And try to like follow
them and create whatever projects because this is
going to give you a lot of more motivation
and a push forward to learn by yourself
and create your own projects. Start sharing
your progress with the developer community.
You could be on Social media like on Twitter,
for example, or discord or somewhere else,
just make sure that you're sharing your progress,
it will give you the needed motivation. There are
many different kinds of motivation that work for
different people. But one of the best things for
me personally, is to follow inspirational people
on social media, I love getting inspired by
different accounts. Also, to force myself to
study, I typically use the two minute rule, which
is just telling yourself that you're going to do
something for two minutes. And after two minutes,
you can stop. But usually, because you gain
momentum, you don't stop after two minutes. So
you kind of trick yourself into spending the time
to do that certain activity. Obviously, that's not
only for programming, it's for everything. But I
find the two minute rule always helps me. And you
know, time blocking every single night, I'm trying
to learn to code from this time to this time.
And sticking to that is super important. I would
say, being part of a community. It's really,
really important, because you'll find like minded
people like yourself, and you'll feel like you're
not alone in this journey. If you are part of
a community, get engaged, ask questions, have
study groups with people meet people. And that
way it will drive you forward every single day,
that days that you will feel like oh, this is
so difficult. And if you are alone, it's much
easier for you to give up. Now, if you are within
a community, and you've got people supporting you,
then you kind of feel you know, someone
uplifting you all the way if you are stuck,
you ask questions. And yeah, just be part of the
community. I think it's one of the best things
that you should do to motivate yourself. Well,
motivation is a short term boost, you need to have
a clear understanding why you're doing this. This
is how you'll make sure that you'll go through
all the rainy days. And all the days where you
don't really want to study at all. And generally
try to switch between activities. Let's say you're
coding than switching to something like running or
lifting weights. This is how you can
split your day and not to get bored
with what you do. This is kind of a difficult
question for me, because I'm a self motivated
learner who wants to learn about
everything, regardless if it's tech,
cars, nature, woodworking, whatever I'm super
interested in learning all the time. So I motivate
myself by finding something I'm interested in.
And then I start reading about it and decide
whether or not it can hold my interest for a long
time. Once I have that I can study all day, every
day about a topic. I think the most fun way to
learn anything is with actual real projects that
are interesting for you. So once you learn the
basics of a programming language from a course,
for example, you can start practicing yourself.
For example, if you want to learn JavaScript,
think about a web application, you would want to
develop for yourself, maybe you love sports. So
you want to develop a web application that shows
all the fun sports events and activities near you.
Whatever it is, this will make it much more fun
to learn coding than just going through a book or
a course with boring generic examples. Sure,
there will always be cases where you have to force
yourself to do a little bit. But I think if you
can find something that you enjoy most something
that feels like a hobby, then the motivation will
be no problem, you will enjoy it so much that you
will continue working on it, you will find any
spare time that you have to put into it. And the
motivation will be no problem at all. So make
sure to find something that makes you happy.
Don't study, build stuff, and study what
you need as you're building stuff to build
this stuff. It's called constructivist learning.
And it's a way of teaching yourself new things.
By doing those things. You don't learn how to make
cabinets. By just thinking about making cabinets,
yo make cabinets by building cabinets, same sort
of thing with software, you learn how to build
software by building software. It was so helpful
to me when I was starting out to really consider
why I was getting into software development.
I was at a complete dead end in my life.
I'd wanted to do this for a long time. And I
finally pushed myself to become a professional
developer back in 2015. One of the ways that
I did that was writing down my reasons, all of
my why's for getting into software development,
where I could see them and remember them. And I
found that very motivating for me. Another thing
that I have realized that can really help you
push through challenges and when you get stuck
is something I call building early and often.
You really need to have have successes along
your journey while you're learning to code.
One of the best ways of measuring success is
by building projects. When you can look back
and see the history of things you have built, and
see how they started from simple little projects
and got slowly more advanced over time,
you can really feel how much you have been
growing and learning. So even when you're stuck
on something, and you feel like I can't do this,
or why can't I just get it, and you start to say
all of these negative things to yourself, you can
look back and say, Wait, I have come so far and
learned so much. This is just a small bump in the
road. And whether I figured this out right now,
or later on, it doesn't matter, I'm still going to
make it to my destination. Always think of it this
way study as if your job depended on it, which it
does. You know how much you study is going to
determine how well you'll be able to break into
the field, the industry. And if you're already
in the industry, how much you study, or how much
you learn in general is going to determine, you
know how fast you go from a junior to a senior.
So as an engineer, you're going to be constantly
studying and learning. Try to do a little bit each
day if you're struggling, you know, use Pomodoro
or something like that. Join studying communities,
there's a lot of them online, go to coffee shops,
go to libraries, wherever it is that it motivates
you to study go there. But in general, just
try to do a little bit each day and you know,
make a routine out of it. And that's really all
you need is just build a system that keeps pushing
you forward. In programming, there is never an end
to learning. There's always something new to learn
about. So don't get overwhelmed. Take breaks
from studying or just reading about something
by building something with the technology that
you're studying about. You're going to learn
so much faster, and it's going to make it more
interesting. Also study things that motivate
you. If you're not interested in something,
then it's going to make it so much harder
to learn about it. Now, I think the most important
thing when you're studying is to find something
you are genuinely interested in. So for example,
if you are currently learning JavaScript and
you're just not into making to do lists, there are
plenty of other things to build out there. If you
want to build a game then definitely find that or
if you want to build a website that is cool too.